NEVER.
AND THAT THE THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION
BY SKYPE, ARE THE
AFOREMENTIONED DIAMOND AND
SILK.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU
LADIES.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> WELL, WE ARE DOING
WONDERFUL.
WE HOPE YOU ARE DOING WELL.
>> YES, NICE TO SEE YOU
BACK.
>> Laura: NICE TO SEE YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S START WITH YOU
DIAMOND, FACEBOOK AND
DIAMOND AND SILK.
YOU GUYS HAVE HAD AN
INTERESTING RELATIONSHIP
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS
OR EVEN MONTHS GIVEN THE
FACT THAT YOU DISCOVERED
THAT YOUR MESSAGES WERE
SUDDENLY NOT GETTING OUT TO
YOUR FOLLOWERS.
YOU KNOW FACEBOOK HAS HAD A
RESPONSE TO THIS.
BUT, FIRST, TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED AND HOW YOU NOTICED
IT.
>> WELL, BACK IN SEPTEMBER
OF 2017 WE NOTICED ALL OF
OUR ENGAGEMENT HAD STOPPED.
>> UM-HUH.
>> WE REACHED OUT TO
FACEBOOK CONTINUOUSLY AND
THEY KEPT GIVING US THE RUN
AROUND, NOTHING IS WRONG
WITH YOUR PAGE.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
IT.
WELL, WE DON'T KNOW AND WE
GOT TO REACH BACK OUT TO OUR
TEAM.
IT WAS A BACK AND FORTH, AND
BACK AND FORTH.
FINALLY THE STRAW WAS THE
OTHER DAY WHEN THEY WROTE
AND THEY SAID THAT THEY
DEEMED OUR CONTENT AND OUR
BRAND UNSAFE TO THE
COMMUNITY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WE ARE THE BRAND.
>> WE THE BRAND.
>> TWO CHICKS DOWN WITH
POLITICS THAT LOVE OUR
PRESIDENT, THAT LOVE OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, WE THE WOMEN
THAT'S BEHIND ALL OF THIS
HERE RIGHT HERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHAT YOU SAID IS WHEN YOU
SAY THAT YOU DEEM US UNSAFE
TO THE COMMUNITY, WHAT YOU
ARE SAY SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE -- WE ARE --
>> A DANGER.
>> A DANGER TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING?
I MEAN, I DON'T GET THAT
IT'S OFFENSIVE.
IT'S APPALLING.
I LOOK AT THIS AS
DISCRIMINATION.
I LOOK LOOK AT THIS AS
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
YOU ARE CENSURING OUR VOICES
VOICES.
>> Laura: SILC, ISN'T IT THE
CASE THAT FACEBOOK DIDN'T
WANT YOUR POST TO REACH YOUR
FOLLOWERS IS BECAUSE YOU ARE
BLACK, YOU ARE CONSERVATIVE,
YOU SUPPORT TRUMP, AND YOU
TELL IT LIKE IT IS AND YOU
CALL IT AS YOU SEE IT THAT'S
OFFENSIVE TO THE LEFT.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE YOU
LENS PEOPLE LIKE YOU, BOTH
YOU, DIAMOND AND SILK,
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT WAS
JUST SILK OR DIAMOND OR
DIAMOND AND SILK, THEY DO
NOT WANT YOU TO REACH
PEOPLE.
I'M SORRY AND I'M GOING TO
SAY IT UNTIL I'M BLUE IN THE
FACE.
>> SAY IT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE AFRAID OF
BOTH OF YOU.
THEY DON'T WANT YOUR VIEWS
OUT.
>> WE ARE WHAT YOU CALL
DOUBLE THREAT.
THEY DO NOT WANT THAT
BECAUSE WE DO NOT FIT THEIR
STATUS QUO OR THEIR
NARRATIVE.
YOU KNOW, WITH US BEING
BLACK PEOPLE, DEMOCRATS ARE
SO USED TO BLACK PEOPLE
BEING ON WHAT WE CALL THE
DEMOCRAT PLANTATION.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO PLAY BY
OUR RULES.
YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE
MUCH.
SO THAT YOU DEPEND ON THE
GOVERNMENT AND WE WILL GIVE
YOU WHAT WE WANT YOU TO HAVE
SO THAT WE CAN CONTROL YOU.
BUT DIAMOND AND SILK, WE CAN
SPEAK FOR OURSELVES.
>> RIGHT.
>> WE HAVE OUR OWN MIND.
>> UM-HUH.
>> WE DON'T LISTEN TO THEIR
NEGATIVE NARRATIVES THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO SPIN OVER
THERE ON THE LEFT.
WE HAVE OUR OWN EYES, 8 OF
THEM, TO SPEAK FOR OURSELF
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES.
WE SEE THE CORRUPTION THAT'S
GOING ON IN WASHINGTON AND
WE THAT'S WHY WE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP WHO IS NOW THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY TRY TO DEEM US AS DUMB
AS IGNORANT AND AS
UNEDUCATED.
OH, HONEY, WE ARE VERY
SMART.
>> UM-HUH.
>> WE SEE RIGHT THROUGH ALL
OF THEIR B.S.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: LET ME READ WHAT
FACEBOOK ORIGINALLY SAID ON
APRIL 5TH.
THE POLICY TEAM HAS COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT YOUR
CONTENT AND YOUR BRAND HAS
BEEN DETERMINED UNSAFE TO
THE COMMUNITY OKAY.
AGAIN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
COMMUNITY THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT OR HOW IT'S UNSAFE
NEITHER DO EITHER OF YOU.
BUT NOW BECAUSE OF ALL THE
PRESSURE, DRUDGE HAD THIS UP
ALL DAY LONG, YOU GUYS HAVE
MOBILIZED ALL YOUR
FOLLOWERS.
MY FOLLOWERS WERE MOBILIZED
AND OUR VIEWERS LAST WEEK AS
WELL.
AND FACEBOOK SAID THIS:  WE
HAVE COMMUNICATED DIRECTLY
WITH DIAMOND AND SILK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
THE MESSAGE THEY RECEIVED
LAST WEEK WAS INACCURATE AND
NOT REFLECTIVE OF THE WAY WE
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE PEOPLE WHO
RUN PAGES ON OUR PLATFORM.
WE HAVE PROVIDED THEM WITH
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
POLICIES AND THE TOOLS THAT
ARE POLITIC
ARE AOLITIC
ARE APPITIC
ARE APPLIIC
ARE APPLICABLE TO THEIR PAGE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
THEM, THAT ACCORDING TO A
FACEBOOK SPOKESPERSON.
LADIES, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT JIB GIBBERISH IS.
>> THEY NEVER COMMUNICATE
TOWSD.
THE LAST COMMUNICATION WE
GOT WAS THEY DEEMED US
UNSAFE FOR THE COMMUNITY.
THEY HAVE NOT REACHED OUT TO
US.
THEY HAVE NOT COMMUNICATED
WITH US.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A WHITE
LIE.
I DON'T LIKE WHITE LIES.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO TELL IT,
TELL THE TRUTH OR GO
SOMEWHERE AND SIT DOWN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THEY DID NOT COMMUNICATE
WITH US.
>> THEY SAID THEY DID.
THEY SAID WE HAVE
COMMUNICATED WITH DIAMOND
AND SILK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> THEY DID NOT.
>> I WAS NOT CONVERSATED
WITH ANYBODY.
>> WE HAVE BEEN FLYING BACK
FROM PITTSBURGH,
PENNSYLVANIA HERE TO NORTH
CAROLINA SO WE COULD BE ON
THE SHOW TONIGHT.
NOBODY HAS COMMUNICATED WITH
DIAMOND AND SILK.
SO THAT IS A LIE.
>> THAT'S A LIE.
>> THEY ARE PUTTING OUT
THERE.
>> THAT'S A LIE.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY WE HAVE
A LIST OF LEFT WING GROUPS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN DEEMED
UNACCEPTABLE ANTIFA, THOSE
LOVELY PEOPLE.
THE YOUNG TURKS NEVER
PROFANE.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, NO
VIOLENCE THERE.
OCCUPY DEMOCRATS, HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT IT IS.
THE POLITICAL RESISTANCE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
ALL OF THOSE GROUPS ARE OKAY
ACCORDING TO FACEBOOK.
ALL RIGHT.
SO YOU ARE MORE OF A THREAT
TO THE COMMUNITY THAN
ANTIFA?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>>
?>
?THAT'S EMBARRASSING.
ZUCKERBERG BETTER BE ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS.
BILLIONAIRE'S BOYS CLUB
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT
DIAMOND AND SILK.
>> EMBARRASSING.
AND DEFAMATION OF OUR
CHARACTER.
WE ARE NOT A DANGER OF
SOCIETY.
WE AIN'T NEVER KILLED
NOBODY.
WE DON'T DO NO DRUGS.
WE AREN'T OUT IN THE STREET.
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO HELP
AMERICA.
>> Laura: YOU ARE DANGEROUS
BECAUSE YOU CHALLENGE THE
LIBERAL ORTHODOXY THAT IF
YOU ARE NOT A TRUMP HATER,
AND IF YOU ARE AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, THEN THERE
HAS GOT TO BE SOMETHING
WRONG WITH YOU.
THEY DID IT -- THEY DO IT TO
TOM SOL.
THEY DO IT TO CLARENCE
THOMAS.
ANYONE WHO IS BLACK THAT
DOESN'T TOE THE LINE THEY
WANT TO DEMON NICE AND
MARGINALIZE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IT
THROUGH MEGA CORPORATIONS.
IT'S NOT GOOD BUSINESS FOR
THEM.
IT'S NOT SMART.
LADIES, DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL BE ADDRESSED TOMORROW?
>> I HOPE IT'S ADDRESSED
TOMORROW.
>> YEAH.
>> I HOPE ZUCKERBERG TELLS
THE TRUTH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> TELL THEM HOW YOU PUT
THESE ALGORITHMS IN PLACE TO
SEE YOU LENT CONSERVATIVE
VOICES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> LET THEM KNOW HOW YOU
MADE A MISTAKE AND HOW YOU
PLAN TO CORRECT THEM.
NOT ONLY ON OUR PLATFORM BUT
EVERY CONSERVATIVE THAT YOU
SILENCE, YOU NEED TO CORRECT
THAT IMMEDIATELY.
>> YES.
>> AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD.
I DON'T WANT TO CARE YOU ARE
PRIVATE BUT OPENED TO THE
PUBLIC, BABY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IT'S GOT TO BE FAIR ON
EACH SIDE.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: ALL I CAN SAY IS I
HUNG OUT WHAT YOU LITTLE BIT
ON ELECTION NIGHT, I HAVE
GOT TO COME DOWN THERE AND
HANG OUT WITH YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS PUT ME IN A GOOD
MOOD.
I THANK GOD FOR SKYPE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
AND WE'LL KEEP FOLLOWING
THIS AND WE HAVE MORE